I'm actually a really poor liar I'm just
I'm just bad at it I felt really weird
antifa has a penchant for lying they're
really good like there's that video
where Jack basobic got punched yeah and
the cops literally watch it and the
woman goes I didn't see anything I
didn't see anything it's like lady the
cops witnessed it shut your mouth yeah
but they just they just lie I mean she
wasn't a good liar to be honest but hey
Jessie Smollett that dude that's intense
lying yeah I think you should get an
Oscar wow
just like Simone biles athlete of the
Year even though she like pulled out of
all the competitions but you know how
they do uh like the Academy Award uh
like actors will make a pitch video to
like try like that's what they said to
do right in like you have like like the
the actors will make like a video
campaigning to win oh I don't know yeah
or something we should make an Emmy
Oscar campaign for Jesse Smollett oh my
goodness this is a really good idea yeah
and you know what he could use our sport
we'll have like slow motion scenes and
it'll be like for your consideration
Jesse Smollett and then it shows him
crying he's like I fought back
I fought back we gotta use some of the
Jim Cramer saying that economy's doing
great better than ever
on lemon singing the Praises of Biden
saying Cass is down five seven I'm
writing this down
we need our own Awards right and Chris
Cuomo saying that he treats stories
about his brother the same as anything
yeah the top we also need like a top
globalist award who's going to get the
most uh most uh and it's always it's
always Klaus
no no it's always just you want an Emmy
who wasn't the one in Emmy was that
Andrew
for your consideration he had to give it
back the fake always Emmys he had a huge
book deal too yeah it's crazy and Chris
Cuomo's Chris Cuomo's book deal is
scrapped too Andrew Cuomo just like
single-handedly ruins that entire family
it's the whole dynasty really you know I
mean I guess he did get the Tappan Zee
Bridge renamed after his dad yeah but I
mean it really should just be the Tappan
Zee Bridge what's it called now the
Mario Cuomo Bridge oh gross the Tappan
Zee Bridge is classic it's in really
Rosy you know I can tell you
you know the Sphinx in Egypt that was by
one of the pharaoh's kids apparently it
took it used to be a lion a giant
Alliance at you and he he carved the
face had the face of it carved out to be
his father's face and they hated it so
much that he disfigured this beautiful
lion statue that they destroyed the nose
is that what happened and that's kind of
the story is that's what I've read bro I
was watching a story I was watching Joe
Rogan oh there was a guy who said that
there used to be water there there was
like water damage on the space like an
east to west river like the largest
river on Earth ran east to west across
the Sahara oh that's great that's ocean
and I said that means the Sphinx is
older than we realized yeah yeah that
was a crazy episode that was so cool
when humans and lions and now we're
totally derailed
a sign we were talking about Julian
Assange
after his father and then how they def
the Egyptians were so angry that he did
that they defaced it I think I think um
I did write this down I think we should
put together a a fake news Emmys yeah we
should have like Jim Cramer saying the
economy is doing well uh you know Joe
Biden saying no mandates you know that
kind of thing Jesse Smollett crying on
TV I think Jesse's gonna take it man
because you gotta let's be real all
right
we offer a prize we offer a prize reward
and he'll definitely have to go I will
quite literally put a get a big thousand
dollar check let's do it and literally
offer it to them and give them give them
a giant one like Happy Gilmore that's
right yeah and they stand holding up the
fake news Emmy Award and take a picture
with it and they they will get a check
for a thousand bucks
for themselves or to the charity of
their choice to them they can literally
I will literally give them a thousand
bucks as a prize for winning but they
got to take a picture holding up the big
check saying fake news Emmys right and
then we'll do a video and we'll
celebrate it they won't accept the money
nobody would I think that's really funny
but look politics aside we all need to
recognize jussie Smollett is one of the
greatest actors of this or any
generation Dr fauci I think is in the
consideration as well for uh the huge
lies that he's been telling the crazy
thing about Smollett too is like he went
out there and he lied in order to
elevate his status as a victim yeah you
know to claim that and and in order to
like show how white supremacists the the
American society is and he hired two
black guys
amazing to beat him up and then he
claimed that those black guys were
homophobic even though one of them he
was like fooling around with or whatever
yeah yeah it's like really you're first
of all that's how you treat your friends
that's how you treat someone that you're
like really into apparently like come on
that sounds like in Hollywood and then
everyone's still standing by him and
it's like really because Smollett would
not stand by you he's through he throws
his boys under the bus yeah honestly
yeah he can lie yeah
when people are backing him still well
because his talent still backing him I I
have to imagine that right now in
Hollywood they're like man I can't
believe Jessie did that but the boy
can't act
he has a film out like some b-boy tells
you really yeah or he was like working
on it he was writing a screenplay during
this whole period of time they couldn't
get any work oh wow no I I mean I mean
you got to do something you know I mean
at least be productive but I do mean
this sincerely I really do think this is
my is talented yeah I I genuinely
believe that you know when he went on TV
and he kept a straight face and the way
he lied and the way he played everybody
the dude really can act and you got to
understand that a lot of these actors
when they're on movie sets they have you
know cut try again cut try again hey try
it like this for just you to be sitting
on the hot seat on GMA and go through
that interview and nail the crying and
everything I genuinely like this this
guy yeah he's got some theater
experience he definitely is good at what
he does he's just a scumbag yeah he's a
great sociopath you know to a certain
extent he wrote a great script like this
should be the script this is the story
nobody cares what he thinks about
anything else like this is the story and
he could play himself yeah absolutely or
he should play one of the osendarians
that would be better yes
Hillary Clinton should also be in the
running she just came out and started
crying after talking after reciting her
uh oh like her speech if she would have
won the presidency how do you do that
like if that were me and I'm selling
that and I had so publicly been
humiliated like that I would never first
of all I would never go back and read
the speech but I would never publicly be
like my goodness to go out there and and
show everybody no no no she's she's now
chilling of course where she's charging
people
money's still backing her we should also
how much Clinton was on the Epstein
plane I would have trouble just like
facing Society I would be like and I'm
over here in China we're gonna have a
tea go quiet and when we do the uh when
we do the Hillary Clinton for your
consideration for the fake news Emmys we
can do one of two things one where she's
like I'm now going to read you my speech
or I have to won the presidency and then
she like briefly turns into a lizard
what's eye drops and gigantic lizard
eyes and then changes back and goes oh
yeah or she could be a robot and she's
in there going engage crying sequence
and then water just sprays out of her
eyes violently like an anime characters
it was watching her cry I'll do air
quotes here I was just like wow does she
think that like P I wonder if she
actually can cry I wonder if she's like
hardcore sociopath and she can't lie
absolutely from my own personal
perspective and opinion I mean what else
do you need to know about a career
politician that literally has celebrated
the brutal torture and death of uh
Muammar Gaddafi uh she literally what
did you say she was like we came we saw
he died
and the videos of what happened to
Gaddafi were absolutely horrific when I
was a kid I lived in uh I lived in
Hanover Massachusetts and for the Fourth
of July one year I think I was in like
fourth or fifth grade there was is a
bonfire with an effigy of Muammar
Gaddafi burned at the stake and everyone
cheered and Love's like Yay Hillary also
people used to make fun of me like all
the kids would make fun of me they'd be
like oh Libby is Gaddafi your uncle
Hillary oh my God you are literally the
stupidest people in all the suburbs it's
amazing Hillary Clinton seems to me like
the kind of person where like she's
smoking a cigarette and she'll like walk
past like a little kid and then just
like put the cigarette out on the kid's
head and flick it no
she is definitely the kind of person to
just pop your balloon just because she
can yeah 100 percent accidentally jostle
your ice cream yeah a little bit well
like you remember that story that that
uh former I think it was an Air Force
guy was to see a secret service guy
wrote a book yeah and he said that he
there was a there was like they were on
a plane and there were Air Force like
officers who were on this plane
transporting Hillary and she holds up
her empty wine glass and goes oh my and
then like these guys are like yo I am
like an officer in the Air Force I'm not
here to pour you wine and she just kept
going like wow cough drop yes are you
coughing ma'am yeah if you'd like to get
up and grab your own drink you might as
well maybe that'll clear your throat
yourself yeah there's a lot of them say
to my kid you know he'll be like Mom
can I have some more juice and I'll be
like yeah well you know right where that
is right over there there's cups and
everything you know where those are my
parents would be like I don't know can
you right yes and I feel like uh like
are you asking for permission because if
you want it you can go and do it
yourself yeah it's like there's so many
stories of these like snobby elitist
trading people absolutely horribly I
remember talking to one of those can we
just pause for a second the snobby
elitists are treating people badly yeah
yeah who would have thought
I have a hunch uh just a little bit
there but I remember even talking to one
of the staff members that was uh helping
out the Bilderberg Group and they were
serving the Bilderberg members and they
were told specifically don't look them
in the eye don't start conversations
don't talk to them uh look down and make
sure that all their needs are served
whenever they might even have a need or
we might think they might have a need
yeah so like Faulty Towers don't talk
about the war yeah and and they
literally can't even look people in the
eyes as they're serving them and they're
supposed to look down the whole time and
it's just utterly ridiculous there's
it's kind of weird with that kind of
elitism now because you'll go places and
the staff is all masked up and you don't
have to and Nancy Pelosi doesn't have to
she's she's very happy
and Marjorie Taylor green like a whole
ton of money for not masking and she
doesn't do it herself someone pointed
out that in uh The Hunger Games that
there was a like the the capital city
had servants who had their tongues cut
out had to wear masks or something I
forgot what they're called you guys
remember that um I forget but they did
they just had their tongues cut out they
didn't have to wear masks oh okay uh no
I'm pretty sure there was there was an
image of them like wearing masks I look
it up yeah I don't know man people in
common and chat can can get us on that
one but is it any surprise to you that
this is what humans do you know what I
mean avoid eye contact when you make eye
contact with someone you're stealing
their energy and you're changing the way
their brain works so these but there's
just people don't want to know there's
no joy in treating people badly you know
for some people there is there's it's
like I I found this too you know during
the pandemic but even before like if I'm
gonna go into a place if I'm going to I
don't know buy something from person or
order something we're both experiencing
this moment of life together like let's
just have it not suck you know let me
acknowledge you you can acknowledge me
we're here together there's no issue I
was in a restaurant on my birthday I
took my son out for like seafood Feast
basically for my birthday which is my
favorite thing and the waitress and this
was down the shore in Jersey uh we were
like hi you know how is it going you
know whatever or order our food and at
the end of the meal she was like I just
want to thank you guys for being so nice
and we were like uh what do you mean and
she was saying that people come in there
they don't look at her they're Gruff
they just complain at her they tip her
poorly like all of the mean things and I
was like but
you're here at this restaurant you you
just brought me a meal that is so nice
you know they're so wonderful that I
could come here and order a meal and you
would bring it to me that's great I'm
I'm so grateful for that it's amazing
what a thing when I got to eat I'm a bit
of a commie and I always tip ridiculous
ridiculously high amounts sure but I
figured out a way to exploit Luke's and
caps
I'm like live left when I'm tipping I'm
like I'm gonna give this waiter 100 tip
and then I'm like now how do I convince
Luke who's who's live right so I make it
a competition yeah and I'm like well
look I'm gonna get the better service
Luke can you handle it looks like I'll
tip better and then Luke ends up tipping
I'm pretty sure I started the last
competition you started the first one
the first one the first one was pretty
hardcore uh and I was like all right we
could play but but at the end of the day
you know it's it's all in a good service
since the people actually serving us do
get you know a lot of support thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time